-My first guest tonight
is an Oscar, Emmy,
and Tony-nominated actor
who stars in the new movie
"Stowaway,"
which is streaming now
on Netflix.
Here is Anna Kendrick!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah!
That's what I'm talking about!
Hey!
Anna, welcome.
Thank you so much
for doing our show again.
It's so good to see you.
-It's so good to see you.
Thanks for having me.
-Please.
It's been probably, I think,
just over a year
since I talked to you last.
-Yeah, yeah, I think --
Yeah, I saw you, like,
right at the beginning of this
whole thing -- that's right.
-Thank you
for doing the show then
and thank you for doing it now.
How -- How have you adapted
to -- to living at home?
-Um. I don't think I've adapted
any better than anybody else.
-[ Chuckling ] Yeah.
-But, I mean, I'm --
I'm trying to, like,
keep it moving, keep busy.
I'm -- I'm doing, like,
my COVID workout thing.
Like, I'm --
-What is that?
-I'm just -- I'm just, like,
watching YouTube videos
of some lady and, like,
trying to follow along,
but, like, because it's
the only thing I have to do,
I've kind of gotten
really into it.
And I'm like -- I'm like,
"Maybe I'm a hard body.
Maybe I'm, like..."
-Wow.
-I'm a --
Like, honey, I'm an athlete.
-Really?
-And then,
it occurred to me recently that,
normally,
I would be doing this stuff,
like, in a class full of people
with the full-length mirrors
just to really illustrate
how much I am not nailing it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But until then, like, I am --
Come on, Simone Biles,
I'm coming for you.
-You're ready for the Olympics?
-Like, I'm -- My --
Oh, my body is poetry in motion.
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, it's a good thing they --
they postponed the Olympics,
'cause I'm coming.
-Wow.
That's what I'm talking about.
-Like, that's where I'm at.
-It's just 'cause there's no --
-Until -- Yeah --
Until things go back to normal,
and I actually see just how
terrible all of the form is.
-[ Chuckling ] Yeah.
-Until then, I'm living
this fantasy. I love it.
-I want to talk to you about
your new movie, "Stowaway."
I'm excited for people
to see this.
It's -- It's set in space and...
-Yeah.
-And although you've
never been to space,
your name has gone to Mars.
Can you explain this?
And this is
the coolest story ever.
-[ Chuckling ] Okay.
So, this is --
the director is,
like, really into space,
and before the movie came out,
he -- he gave me --
he actually sent me this --
this thing, where he was like,
"I got" -- it was crazy --
"I got your name and the name
of all of the cast members,
like, engraved
on the Mars rover."
And I just was like,
"Wait. What?
Like, this can't be real.
Holy cr--"
And so, I ended up having to,
like, research what this was,
and it was one of those things
where it's like --
it is a lovely gift,
but, first of all,
now I'm doing research,
so already I don't like
this gift as much,
'cause it's homework.
[ Laughter ]
-Any gift
that makes you do research...
-You've given me
the gift of homework.
[ Laughter ]
And -- And so, what it is --
Do you guys have --
-Yes.
-I think you have, like,
a photo.
-I do.
This is the Mars rover.
And this is like --
this is amazing to me.
This is -- Of course,
this is the Mars rover.
-Incredible.
-Yes.
And now your name
is somehow on here?
-[ Laughs ] Okay.
So, there's apparently --
this is what the article said
that I found in my research,
was there are three
fingernail-size chips
on the -- this little placard
on the Mars rover where --
-And you are one
of the fingernails?
-I'm one of the fingernails,
but 11 million names are
on these fingernail-sized chips.
-So --
-Yeah, there it is. Just these.
-In one of these chips...
-In one of these is my name,
along with
11 million other names.
Very cool.
-So it's still --
Technically, your name --
You -- You --
-Oh, technically my name
is in space, guys.
-Yeah!
That's what I'm talking about!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You -- You are on Mars
as we speak!
You -- You were told,
and everyone knows this,
don't ever work with animals,
don't work with kids,
and -- and someone told you...
-Yeah.
-...don't ever
do a movie in space.
-Well -- Okay, so, yeah.
The --
There's don't work with kids,
don't work with animals.
A production designer
told me to add,
"Never do a movie in space
or on a submarine,"
because, apparently, it's like
just miserable to shoot
because it's so cramped --
like, it's such close quarters,
and you have to get, like,
the crew in there
and the camera people in there.
-Ohh, gosh.
-And so, you know,
when they're doing these,
like, tracking shots,
where they're walking
in front of me,
I'm, like, trying to signal
the camera guy, like,
"You're going to run
into the thing,"
and it's just very, like...
-Oh, 'cause
they're just walking, yeah.
-You know.
-That's the tricky thing.
-It's just very claustrophobic.
-They're going backwards, and
they're, like, banging into --
Yeah, you're like,
"No, oh, gosh."
-Yeah.
-So, yeah. Tough job.
-Yeah, this is where
I really found out
I'm just, like, a klutz.
I just --
I'm capable of breaking
anything, no matter the size.
-Netflix was kind enough
to send us
a few of these moments
[Chuckling] of yours.
So here are a few of Anna's
outtakes from "Stowaway."
Take a look.
[ Beeps ]
-Ready, and action!
-Jesus Christ!
[ Laughter ]
-Cut, cut, cut.
-Okay, cut.
[ Beeps ]
-Ohh [bleep].
-[ Laughs ]
-I'm breaking the ship.
I broke the ship.
-Abort, abort!
-[ Laughs ] "Break--
Breaking the ship!
Breaking the ship!"
-"She's breaking the ship!"
-"I broke the ship."
-"I'm breaking the ship."
-No, it's like, "Are you okay?"
This movie's an intense movie,
like,
an edge-of-your seat movie.
Would you like to set it up for
everybody -- what it's about?
-Yeah, so it's --
it's three astronauts
on a two-year mission to Mars,
and they have enough resources
for three people,
and about 12 hours
into the flight
that they cannot
turn around from,
they discover a stowaway.
And it's kind of the questions
of, like,
how do we all survive together,
and what do we do
if there's really only enough
oxygen for three of us?
-Ohh.
-So it's the...
Yeah, it is very, like,
nail-bitey.
-I want to show everyone a clip
from the film.
Here's Anna Kendrick
in "Stowaway."
Take a look.
-You're gonna be feeling
full gravity on the roof.
A little over 200 meters
to the solar panels,
but the higher you go,
the less gravity you'll feel.
-Roger.
-Do not touch the tether
with the clamps --
it's carrying the power down
from the solar panels.
-Loud and clear.
Don't climb the power tethers.
[ Breathing deeply ]
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-How cool is that?!
Anna Kendrick, everybody.